you look simply fantastic you know I
went back in I don't know what to say
about me I I jumped I snuck into your
dressing room to say hello to you before
the show true story I I pushed the door
down and and said to say hello and you
and I started getting you look
absolutely fantastic and I was asking
you about exercise and you started doing
all these amazing stretches in front of
me I was very impressed he's in amazing
shape let me just tell you oh please no
you I and I know you're going to want to
applaud in agreement but please
don't what the hell was
that um shock and awe yeah no I am not
limber I I like to think I'm in pretty
good shape but I I am a very one of
those uptight Irish Catholics I bend
about 10 degrees shocked to hear that
yeah yeah no one knew that but uh but
I'm not very uh I'm not very limber at
all you know you you were really bending
and twisting and it was I got some good
footage you're trying to get me to do
some of that aren't you no no no no I
had a camera who
yeah
what was
that you know we just watched this scene
where the and Sophia varara and I want
to make sure that people understand that
the the uh the plot of of the movie is
that the two of you are paying John
Truro for sex for sex and I the minute I
heard this I thought that's completely
implausible you do not need to pay
anybody for sex that's ridiculous and
then you thought I know that perhaps
there's another career for me for
me no one would pay me for
sex people people pay me to stay away
they did what would you charge very
little like a buck 99 even then I'd be
it'd be like the 99 Cent Store nothing
over if I was a jiggo it would be
nothing over a dollar I would just want
the I mean I maybe this is sexist maybe
I'm wrong but obviously I just I just
don't think that you would be in that
position that's that's absurd you're
trying to get me to say that I would pay
for sex aren't you I'm not trying to get
you to do
anything hubba
hubba this is why I'm a bad jiggalo I
thought this was
sexy while I'm like and hey hi there how
are
you Andy's the better
jiggalo but uh do you think that that's
that's was at my dressing room when you
left and I am
[Applause]
limber I knew something was going on in
there uh but what let's talk about that
that premise that uh women beautiful
women paying men for sex it's just maybe
maybe I'm sexist let's talk about it
yeah you think it's possible I do really
okay you think it's exists in the
culture women saying you I've noticed
more and more I read a lot and I've
noticed more and more as particularly as
a theme in books of fiction that it's
it's prevalent now a lot yes I think
ever since the um 50 Shades of Gray kind
of thing right that everybody wants to
hear about that you can buy sex in works
of fiction and screenplays and
everything it's becoming a Hot Topic
well what's interesting to me is and I
love John churo the actor but you'd
think of a male jiggalo as being this
almost like a chip andell's dancer type
looking guy which is not really the John
that would be a little bit in
intimidating probably if a guy like that
showed up I think you probably want a
guy to show up who seems
nice
really I don't know and then I could be
a jiggalo I I've been going at this the
wrong way I'm serious I thought to to be
a jiggalo I had to like have top 10
qualities you'd like to see I thought I
would have to have like a chiseled chest
and you have a chiseled body no not that
kind of
chiseled I was injured by a chisel as a
child it's very different but I'm just
curious you know how it I mean uh so
you're saying that you do you look for
imperfections in men do you like
imperfections well I think everybody
likes imperfections because let's face
it nobody's perfect and so you look at
people and it's the things that you find
Charming about them everybody likes
different things right when people have
that scar here you know I think that's
cute Harrison Ford has like a little
scar on his I know and uh and he's not
bad no women go crazy for him I'm going
to go punch out my face when the
show go put my head through a plate
glass window kiss
me